in this video we demonstrate how a user
can interactively label the Freedy world
around them the user walks into a room
holding only a consumer death camera
they can instantaneously start scanning
a dense 3d model at their environment
now we see a user simply touching a
surface issuing a voice command labelled
floor to interactively segment and label
the surface or object in question
now let's label a chair just by touching
it and saying label chair
notice how the label propagates across
the surface in question
allowing interactive segmentation of the
Frehley model during acquisition let's
label the table
we can draw a simple stroke around the
smaller object such as this banana
let's also label this market our system
is continuously learning as the user
specifies these object labels now at
this point our real-time 3d recognition
engine kicks in notice how other chairs
with similar geometry and appearance
have also been labeled green as we
scanning new parts of the well these are
also automatically labeled by our
recognition engine note our labels
become refined over time notice how
these yellow chairs have somewhat
confused our recognition engine however
because our system is fully interactive
we can easily correct these recognition
errors
our system allows these new object
classes to be trained in an online
manner and now these new additional
chairs are recognized
our system makes labeling segmenting and
learning from the 3d world around us the
fun and interactive process it also
allows for 3d recognition that is
tailored or personalized for the users
environments and objects of preference
in just under two minutes we've captured
a full dense 3d model of our environment
which is broken down into separate
object classes